Philadelphia's sanctuary city status is
under intense fire after the brutal rape
of a five-year-old girl by an illegal
immigrant and the US Attorney for the
Eastern District of Pennsylvania which
oversees Philly says he's had enough
William McSwain recently sat down with
us about his efforts to fight back
against the city sanctuary policies and
their devastating consequences mr.
McSwain thank you for joining us good to
have you with us so your US attorney in
very important city of Philadelphia and
there is a big controversy there as you
are acutely aware of involving the
sanctuary status of Philadelphia tell me
why from your perspective and then we're
gonna get into this specific case why
your perspective sanctuary status is
harmful for public safety well
fundamentally those of us in law
enforcement aren't supposed to play
favorites those of us who are
prosecutors aren't supposed to play
favorites that's a fundamental principle
because we are supposed to enforce the
rule of law and that means that we're
supposed to enforce the law in a fair
non partisan manner
the problem with sanctuary cities is
they sort of turned that whole principle
on its head and a politicized law
enforcement how do you mean I mean that
what they stand for they stand for the
proposition that a certain group of
people are not going to be subject to
our laws for political purposes namely
we're talking about illegal immigrants
well they make the opposite claim those
who are defending the sanctuary city
policies including the mayor and his
boosters mayor Kenny and his boosters
they'll say actually sanctuary status
keeps the place safer because illegal
immigrants won't go to the authorities
otherwise because they're going to be
afraid of being deported so it actually
makes a city less safe if you don't have
a sanctuary policy in place how do you
respond to that I think actually they
have it exactly backwards they do say
that they think that it fosters trust
among the community and law enforcement
order did not enforce the immigration
laws but actually I think what Foster's
trust between the community and law
forcement is when the community knows
that law enforcement is not going to
play favorites if they know that the
rule of law is going to be respected the
broader community
therefore believes that law enforcement
is doing their job so when the
proponents of sanctuary cities make that
argument that you just articulated I
think they have it exactly backwards
well the DA of Philadelphia Larry
Krassner he is not too pleased with your
criticism of the sanctuary city policy
he said about your statement linking
this rape by this one Ramon Vasquez who
was released ended up raping a member of
his own family a five-year-old child he
said well that's very dramatic to
somehow link the sanctuary status to
this rape the Trump administration has
made it so that immigrant children can
get raped because they're afraid to call
the police due to its policies of
deporting people who are victims so
they're linking Trump to you the
deportation of actual victims of
domestic violence and you're seeing this
bubble up with the judge versus Jeff
Sessions yesterday so how do you respond
to that now he's hitting you hard saying
you're just basically this is typical
Trump administration stuff from you I
think that fundamentally the problem
with that statement is that statement is
a political statement he's going
political I am doing my best as a law
enforcement officer to enforce the law
any neutral non partisan apolitical
manner and when you are proponent of
sanctuary cities you're actually again
you're politicizing law enforcement I
think that the DA in Philadelphia
unfortunately takes a political approach
to a lot of issues in law enforcement
and what I'm saying is that respect for
the rule of law is a non partisan but
the immigration force we're not a
federal immigration force we have our
hands full already well the fundamental
problem again is that not only our
sanctuary cities in my view wrong but
they're essentially unamerican let me
explain that a little bit when you come
before the law in America it's not
supposed to matter who you are or where
you're from
all your parents are or the like
everybody is supposed to be treated
equally so if you politicize the law and
you say we're not going to enforce the
law against a certain group of people
were only going to enforce it against
others you're essentially doing
something that I believe is unamerican
because you're not respecting the rule
it's not equal justice under the law
breath one Ramon Vasquez let's get back
to that case 2014 he was arrested on
aggravated assault
he was released he's a legal immigrant a
year and a half later he was canoe he
was found to have raped a member of his
own family five year old little girl and
then of course the you know when he's
released in 2014 that was sanctuary City
time and they say well making that leap
from his release to the rape and
sanctuary policies that's unfair do you
squarely obviously it's his fault for
doing the rape he's liable but did the
sanctuary City policy facilitate the
rape of this little girl and not only
facilitated its 100% responsible for it
and that is non-controversial what
happened in the timeline was mr. Vasquez
was deported in 2009 he then illegally
re-entered the country he was arrested
for assault in 2014 and we placed a
detainer on him which is a request that
if he's released from local custody they
give the feds a heads-up we take him to
federal custody we deport him
unfortunately Philadelphia because they
are a sanctuary city do not respect
detainers so when mr. Vasquez was
released in 2014 we didn't know about it
the Philadelphia prison officials didn't
tell us about it and instead of him
coming into federal custody where he
would have been deported to Honduras and
had no opportunity to commit any further
crimes in Philadelphia the study went
into the community and as you said he
raped a five year old mayor Kenny
you might have seen this video one or
two or three times reacted to that court
ruling that affirmed the ability to have
this sanctuary status without any
federal you know de munition and funding
and he did the big Snoopy dance let's
watch where is it
a sanctuary city so he's thrilled that
they could cut off access to the feds to
the city arrest database so the federal
government could not get in even if they
wanted to get access in this sanctuary
policy they could not have access even
to know who's in who's in the pros in
the state pen correct and one of the
larger issues at stake here is that in
the post 9/11 world it's very very
important that all levels of law
enforcement state local federal that
they're talking about after 9/11
everyone supposed to talk to each other
obviously FBI CIA but aren't we all
supposed to be working together as
Americans to keep our communities our
country safe I don't I really do not
understand the sanctuary stuff I don't I
don't get it the problem is prior to
9/11 a lot of law enforcement were in
silos they weren't talking to each other
they weren't communicating we've made a
lot of progress since then and I think
that having for example a sanctuary city
policy where the locals are not
communicating with the federal
authorities and in fact defying federal
law is a step backwards and we do that
at our own peril now you're not a
political figure but you live in
Philadelphia you live in the area what
was your sense about the constituents
I mean minorities the poor the
disadvantaged are the ones who are
victimized the most by recidivist
illegal immigrant crime any sense about
how they're feeling about this mayor
again I think that what people want is
they want to know that there are law
enforcement officers whether they're
federal or local or state are enforcing
the rule of law in a non partisan fair
manner treating everybody fairly and is
fundamentally on American and
fundamentally unfair to not enforce the
law against an entire population any
sense about these nationwide injunctions
the sanctuary City D fund you know that
was one Federal District Court ruling we
have other individual federal district
court rulings on immigration well first
of all on that sanctuary cities case
that you mentioned earlier the last word
hasn't been written on that there was a
case in the Eastern District of
Pennsylvania in my district that was
ruled on but there's lots of these cases
going on around the
country and they all sort of percolate
their way up through the quarters
supposed to there shouldn't be a
nationwide injunction with one District
Court Judge or should there be no there
shouldn't and what you want is you want
several courts to look at an issue have
the benefit of all of their analysis and
eventually these things hopefully make
the way to Supreme Court which will have
the final word are you having fun as the
US Attorney at Philadelphia it's a
pretty cool job it's it's a lot of work
but yes I'm doing my best enjoying it
thank you missing saying great - great
to see you thank you